a long handshake intended perhaps to
convey the growing closeness between
Russian President Vladimir Putin and
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un
the two met at the vostokchny cosmodrome
Russia's most modern space launch
facility
the venue possibly a hint Russia may
help North Korea develop military
Satellites after pyongyang's two failed
attempts at launching a spy satellite
earlier this year
Russia in return is looking for weapons
to support its war in Ukraine
U.N resolutions which Russia as a
permanent member of the security Council
had agreed to ban North Korea from
exporting weapons and also from
receiving technical cooperation in
nuclear science the U.S has warned the
two countries may be looking to sign an
arms deal Putin did not directly address
this
of course we need to discuss the issues
of economic cooperation and humanitarian
issues as well as the situation in the
region
that has openly supported Russia's war
on Ukraine
I had an in-depth discussion with
comrade Putin about the political and
Military situation on the Korean
Peninsula and in Europe we found
satisfying consensus on further
strengthening strategic cooperation and
solidarity in the struggle to defend
Sovereign rights and security and to
ensure lasting peace in the region and
the world
some analysts say North Korea appears to
have the upper hand in Striking a deal
with Russia on the North Korean side I
think the upside is very large which is
that the Russians are desperate and the
North Koreans can give this ammunition
and in exchange they can get stopped
they really can't develop the
Technologies has been mentioned for
nuclear subpower or for satellites so
and I think though the benefits really
fall best for the uh North Koreans
there are no specific details of what
has been agreed between the two leaders
Kim's visit to Russia is not over
Reports say he may go on to visit a
factory that manufactures fighter jets
there's no doubt the rest of his visit
will continue to be closely followed by
analysts for hints on other possible
areas of cooperation between Russia and
North Korea Florence Louis Al Jazeera
Seoul
well let's speak to Daniel Hawkins who
joins us now from Moscow Daniel from
Russian pal many crab dumplings to a
full Naval parade it seems Kim is really
getting the full red red carpet
treatment here
yeah in terms of a Pomp and Ceremony
this is as close to the Hollywood
treatment as you can get on a visit to
Russia the highest ranking ministers
politicians defense officials present on
both sides in these bilateral talks and
how interesting would it have been yeah
to be a fly on the wall or better at the
table at those bilateral talks just to
get a look at that fantastic menu in
scenes reminiscent of the old Soviet era
Banquets the two leaders uh toasted each
other
um gave National Proverbs Kim Jong-un
offering Russia unconditional support
for moscow's foreign policy primarily in
the so-called special military operation
in Ukraine Vladimir Putin in return
citing North Korean Proverbs and hailing
the decades-long relationship between
Moscow and Pyongyang you can't exactly
call this a reset in North Korea Russia
relations because the relationship has
been very long stretching back decades
to the Soviet hero the Korean War
and the decades beyond that but
certainly this will be hailed perhaps as
at the start of a new chapter in Russia
North Korean relations at a very key
time for Moscow and sermons of its
foreign relations and although no
official documents or agreements were
signed after these talks certainly
behind closed doors in talks that last
around four hours many interesting
questions will have been decided and no
doubt some interesting agreements would
have been reached no doubt well we've
been hearing that Moscow wants more
ammunition but how much is it actually
likely to give in return beyond all of
this pump and rhetoric
there's certainly been a lot of talk
about some sort of arms deal there's no
doubt about that though as I say Moscow
and Pyongyang have denied these claims
so far having said that there's been
some illusion
um from Top officials uh towards
increased defense Corporation between
these two countries such as military
drills for example and we can take some
of what's to come perhaps from Kim
jong-un's itinerary traveling traveling
on was the Vladivostok to come where
he's going to see the Russian Pacific
Fleet he's going to visit factories
producing Aviation military Aviation
military jets for that matter as well
Vladimir Putin was more expansive saying
that there's a whole a range of spheres
for cooperation ranging from transport
and Logistics mentioning the so-called
Logistics triangle between Russia North
Korea and China also saying there's room
for cooperation in agriculture in North
Korea of course which has suffered quite
regular quite severe food shortages even
famines at times this will be absolutely
key for Russia which likes to uh portray
itself as an image of a very key
exporter of grain fertilizer to
developing States North Korea could
indeed be a very important partner both
leaders will be very keen to show that
they are far from isolated and North
Korea the Kim Jong-un particularly
alluding also to this Coalition against
um imperialism against hegemony in the
East Pacific something that ties in very
much with moscow's rhetoric and policies
as well so although we won't know for
sure what agreements have been agreed as
I say behind closed doors certainly both
sides will be hoping to get something a
very key from these bilateral talks a
visit we'll continue watching very
closely here on now to zero for you
Daniel Hawkins there with the latest
from Moscow thanks Daniel